sait-on que la démocratie française
permet à tous les citoyens d'aspirer à
la plus haute magistrature en 1947 pas
besoin de 500 signatures chaque français
peut prétendre à l'elysée voici dans son
bourg monsieur renoir vernisseurs y mène
sa campagne à coups de canon un canon
qui comme dit l'autre n'a jamais tué
personne mais en 1962 avec la réforme de
la constitution
les règles changent
le président est dorénavant élu au
suffrage universel direct et il y à
quelques contraintes le candidat doit
être appuyé par 100 personnes mais pas
n'importe qui pas n'importe qui il faut
que ce soit des élus d'au moins 10
départements différents et voilà comment
le système de parrainage est né sans
signature suffisait à l'époque pas assez
pour certains vous même vous vouliez
aller plus loin exigé 2000 signes et
bien moi j'avais demandé 2000 signatures
pour donner davantage de rigueur il
fallait une assise électorale
extrêmement élargie et non pas réduite à
100 signatures ce qu'ils veulent ce qui
ne permet pas malheureusement d'écarter
les candidatures fantaisistes
écarter les candidatures fantaisistes
voilà le but des parrainages une
contrainte qui va se renforcer en 1981
où les prétendants doivent récolter 500
signatures de quoi agacer certains comme
l'écologiste brice lalonde il n'hésitait
pas à porter ses feuilles de parrainage
sur les plateaux télé alors je voudrais
publique l'eau puisque vous êtes pour la
démocratie vous demander de prendre
l'engagement
et je vais vous faire transmettre ses
feuilles et de signer pour un candidat
qui ne soit pas celui de votre parti je
ne vous donnerai pas ma signature quelle
que soit la sympathie que je peux avoir
pour certaines de vos préoccupations
bien tenté mais raté les fameuses 500
signatures sont donc une quête de tous
les instants surtout pour les petits
candidats qui ne sont pas portés par des
partis pour une quête qui fait l'objet
de nombreux sujets télé tous les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
continuent leur chasse aux fameuses
signatures la chasse aux signatures il
lui manque encore 19 signature la chasse
aux signatures qui se poursuivent et à
chaque fois les maires qui sont les élus
les plus nombreux sont courtisés mais
pour certains on ne leur fait pas nous à
chaque fois l'issue est la même c'est la
poubelle
ce qui importe pour le candidat c'est
d'avoir des 500 signatures penser ça le
mr bah il est temps qu'ils sept ans il
entend pas mal dernière difficulté en
date les parrainages sont aujourd'hui
100% public conséquence les élus ne
veulent pas se mouiller la chasse aux
précieuses 500 signatures se transforme
vraiment en quête du graal pour certains
candidats
[Musique]